welcome to Hannity we begin tonight with
a Fox News Alert what a night this has
been we have a fully loaded show I begin
tonight I have seen a lot of state of U
of the union's over the years tonight
perhaps by far the best I've ever seen I
am now my 31st year on the radio my 24th
year I'm honored to work here at the Fox
News Channel tonight every American
should be proud of their country we are
now looking and observing a tale of two
very different Americans always hear
about choice elections we're about to
have one at 273 days on one side you
have the Democratic Party that do
nothing Democrats they have offered
nothing but three years of hate rage
never-ending witch-hunt socialism
conspiracy theories lies slander Bruce
murchman character assassination now
it's the party that wants to what
nationalize everything even supporting
infanticide and abortion after birth as
the Virginia Governor told us on the
other side you saw the president tonight
he is pushing prosperity freedom
security and moments ago he delivered
the compelling uplifting speech of his
life highlighting America's
groundbreaking successes over the past
365 days really the last three years job
jobs in America booming income in
America soaring poverty in America is
plummeting crime is falling competence
surging the country is thriving and we
are highly respected all over the world
tonight was about American greatness and
includes brave men and women who make
this country the single greatest place
God ever gave men and moments ago the
president honored the parents of Kayla
Mueller the US aid worker who was
murdered by Isis he also honored tonight
a little girl who received a new
scholarship tonight to advance her life
and her education
we met at General tonight it was one of
the last surviving Tuskegee Airmen and
we met a brave member of this country's
Border Patrol as well as the brother of
a man killed by an illegal immigrant
tonight and this special moment with the
family of an American soldier serving
abroad
it brought the house down take a look
but Amy there is one more thing tonight
we have a very special surprise I am
thrilled to inform you that your husband
is back from deployment he is here with
us tonight
wowthat's shock and awe now despite all
of these powerful moments what did we
see tonight
Democrats barely cracking a smile I have
no idea what Nancy Pelosi was doing it
almost looked like a Saturday Night Live
skit for the entire speech they are
clearly living tonight in a very
different alternative reality another
America that I don't recognize one full
of non-stop never-ending hatred rage and
witch hunts and conspiracy theories look
at your screen tonight Pelosi trying so
hard
look how miserable she was at the end of
the president's speech tonight she
ripped up her copy of the President's
speech and has just defended doing so
one of the most classless things ever
done in the history of the State of the
Union and all throughout the night she
could barely bring herself to stand up
for the roaring economy or any of
America's great achievements let's take
a look the veterans unemployment rate
dropped to a record low
a record number of young Americans are
now employed real median household
income is now at the highest level ever
recorded we will always protect patients
with pre-existing conditions
drug overdose deaths declined for the
first time in nearly 30 years Wow
pretty powerful now all throughout the
night we will be listing and we'll be
showing the president's accomplishments
that he talked about tonight
accomplishments for we the American
people
Pelosi didn't even stand for the little
girl who received a scholarship is that
not something every American can agree
on apparently not
take a look an opportunity scholarship
has become available it's going to you
and you will soon be heading to the
school of your choice
remember we were talking about Baltimore
and we identified 13 high schools all
these liberal cities that have been run
for decades by Liberal Democrats 13 high
schools in in Baltimore alone where not
a single kid proficient in reading and
math not one we can't fail our kids like
that god bless that girl and good luck
to her in her future and Nancy Pelosi
barely even applauding any of the
president special guests imagine being a
Democrat and having that much rage that
much hate that much contempt in your
heart and of course Pelosi his
Democratic colleagues were just as bad
many of them they wouldn't even cheer
for the historic advancement when the
president mentioned women in the
workplace 72 percent of the new jobs
created for women in this country watch
this a tale of two Americas at last year
women filled 72 percent of all new jobs
added
see a lot of women in white that's not
worth standing for now despite the
unyielding rage from the Democrats
president well he delivered a powerful
optimistic patriotic speech with real
statistics and stand success behind it
conservatism works it's working now and
it's working for the American people
take a look jobs are booming incomes are
soaring
poverty is plummeting crime is falling
confidence is surging and our country is
thriving and highly respected again this
is a blue-collar boom members of
Congress we must never forget that the
only victories that matter in Washington
are victories that deliver for the
American people the people are the heart
of our country their dreams are the soul
of our country and their love is what
powers and sustains our country we must
always remember that our job is to put
America first public servants serving
the people look at your screen since the
president has taken office our economy
has generated over 7 million new jobs
the unemployment rate is now the lowest
in over half a century the unemployment
rates for African Americans Hispanic
Americans Asian Americans have reached
the lowest levels in history we have a
record number of young Americans that
are now employed african-american
poverty has now declined to the lowest
rate ever recorded a 70 year record low
unemployment for women in this country
72 percent of all new jobs added are
going to women in the workforce veteran
unemployment that rate dropping again to
a record low the unemployment rate for
disabled Americans a record low all-time
low the unemployment rate for workers
without a high school diploma is now at
a record low 7 million of our fellow
Americans are off of food stamps 10
million
people have been lifted off of welfare
the net worth of the bottom half of wage
earners in America has increased by a
whopping 47% low-income workers in
America have seen a 16 percent pay
increase median household income is now
at the highest level ever recorded
12,000 new factories home who said those
jobs are not coming back a booming stock
market that means America is winning
America's forgotten men and women are
winning tonight speech was not just
about the massive success of the Trump
agenda the president also he took time
along with the first lady Melania Trump
and they gave a very special award to
one of the single most influential
important stoic voices this country has
ever known
let's take a look here tonight is a
special man beloved by millions of
Americans who just received a stage for
advanced cancer diagnosis this is not
good news but what is good news
is that he is the greatest fighter and
winner that you will ever meet
rush limbaugh thank you for your decades
of tireless
to our country
I thought the left celebrated the free
open exchange of ideas and opinions but
apparently not conservative ones and we
pray for Rush Limbaugh tonight he is a
fighter well deserved my friend neil
bortz call rush the Babe Ruth of talk
radio he paved the way for all of us
that do opinion and talk radio in the
country there was a forest he cleared
the path we all got to walk through an
easier path because of him perhaps
knowing in modern history has advanced
the cause of patriotism free speech love
of country love of the Constitution of
the United States more than rush without
rush well nothing I do here would be
possible that path that he forged for
all of us in the conservative movement
all over America and fought each and
every single day to make this a more
perfect union everyone who has ever
battled cancer knows someone who has
battled cancer you do understand how
difficult how earth-shattering this
diagnosis can be you know some of the
same politicians that have well they go
on controversial shows like Don Imus who
just passed away or Howard Stern they go
on his show he said controversial things
we ought to celebrate freedom of speech
whether you agree or disagree but we are
blessed to live in a country they thank
God we have the greatest the best
scientists and doctors and healthcare
professionals anywhere in the world and
Russia is blessed with a wonderful
family a deep unyielding faith belief in
God we all pray for his speedy recovery
tonight and coming up we'll have more of
that powerful moment if we also have
full reaction tonight analysis to the
president's address from Senator Ted
Cruz Lindsey Graham Ivanka Trump so much
more we also have a lot of other big
breaking news to cover today and we will
start with what is known as the dumpster
fire of the Iowa Democratic caucus
the Trump campaign called it the
sloppiest trainwreck in history that's
probably an understatement it has been
more than 24 hours since the votes took
place we still do not have the full
results and for the better part of the
day we didn't have any results at all
nothing democratic party blaming it on
oil coating error in its election
software and problems with its backups
Wow kind of reminds me of their promises
of Obamacare keep your doctor keep your
plann on average save $2,500 a year
millions lost their doctors millions
lost their plan we all pay almost 200%
more we didn't save anything and almost
40% of Americans only have one option
for an Obamacare exchange that's the
promise of the left same people that
have destroyed one big city in this
country after another they want to
control your healthcare they want to
control your businesses now they want to
nationalize the entire energy sector the
lifeblood of the world's economy and
they can't even count a few thousand
boats in the state of Iowa I don't trust
them it's pathetic and tonight it is
clear and it's not actually not clear
why a huge percentage of the vote is
m.i.a we have no idea what really
happened one thing we can tell you and
that certain Bernie Sanders his
supporters well it looks like they're
after Bernie again seemed like we were
an island here when poor Donna Brazile
had to call Bernie Sanders as we told
you last night and see they stack the
deck against you they rigged it are they
drinking it again likely Iowa
frontrunner could have been robbed
nobody will know quid pro quo Joe he's
been given ample cover for what looks
like a pathetic fourth place finish a
disaster for him now this comes on the
heels of more panicked attempts by the
DNC officials well they want to change
the rules again because they think
Bernie has a shot at winning look at
this political report that came out
yesterday some have discussed quote
changing the rules to give the
super-delegates more power they want the
votes to count like they did in
Hillary's 2016 election and recently the
party rewrote debate qualifications well
Biden's falling apart so maybe you'll
help Mike Bloomberg in case we need him
at some point and by the way maybe he
can buy his way onto the debate stage
even Michael Moore is furious about that
this is 2016 on steroids all over again
history more than repeating itself
remember it cheated Bernie and then they
used the dirty Russian dossier that they
leaked to the press and then we found
out that they took away one person civil
rights Carter page his civil liberties
why so they could backdoor and spy on a
presidential campaign of donald trump
than history
addition team and then deep into his
presidency all of that happened and that
dirty Russian dossier Hillary Clinton
paid for
apparently Democrats didn't care about
Russian and appearance only if it was
Donald Trump which didn't happen or
Ukrainian interference which we're told
also happened as chronicled by the
January 11th 2017 political
investigation and by a Ukrainian Court
that's right a DNC operative going into
the Ukrainian embassy to get dirt on
Donald Trump and others nobody seemed to
care like they don't care about quid and
pro and quo Joe you're not getting the
billion unless you fire the prosecutor
investigating my zero experience on
being paid millions this continues we
are on the verge of a civil war within
the Democratic Party
they will soon nominate a radical devout
communist well in the case of Bernie
Sanders actually honeymooned in the
Soviet Union you can't make this up or
another radical socialist will pretend
to be a moderate in a general election
and will inspire nobody look at the
enthusiasm gap
now despite essentially running
uncontested president indeed much many
people to show up in Iowa last night but
guess what massive amount of Iowa
Republicans turned out to caucus for
President Trump look at these reports it
was the most ever for a sitting
president and meanwhile Democratic
numbers they're way down from the Obama
years as one article put it quote
Democrats were counting on Barack Obama
levels of enthusiasm and they got
Hillary Clinton numbers instead and a
friendly reminder
Hillary lost the state of Iowa and lost
the election and then fast forward to
today and now it's important to ask
yourself and this is for any election
are you better off than you are four
years ago look at your screen perhaps
you'll find the answer there because I
think the answer is pretty clear on
every single promise that the president
make it that the president keep it by
the way these polls are now reflecting
the president's tremendous success look
at the Gallup poll out today showing
that the president's approval numbers
are at an all-time high according to the
same poll Americans confidence in the
economy is higher than at any point in
the past two decades national
satisfaction is the highest in nearly 15
years in fact it is the highest economic
approval rate
not only for Donald Trump but for any
president since George W Bush enjoyed
the stratospheric job approval ratings
in the first few months after the
September 11 2001 terrorist attacks and
that's not all
look at this new Zogby poll the
president's approval rating is about 50%
an expanding base of minority and
suburban voters surprise surprise it
looks like the president's
accomplishments are paying off and
Democrats three plus years of doing
nothing absolutely nothing except
conspiracy theories lies hoaxes of
witch-hunts not particularly doing well
for them and tomorrow the latest insane
charade will officially be over thank
god the president will be acquitted with
even possible bipartisan support even
moderate Republicans Susan Collins she
made a compelling case why she is voting
no on both articles of impeachment - she
is voting to acquit and you the American
people in 273 days you will be the
ultimate jury you will render the final
verdict and you have the ability and the
opportunity to once again shock the
world